now let's get it all in perspective for
all y'all enjoy me the song y'all can
step with Marvel has always had his
finger on the pulse of pop culture and
this right here just taking it even
further as fresh as new as innovative
from a musical perspective Ali and I
look at this as we're creating 13 albums
no I'm saying it's 13 episodes like 13
helps all the episodes are named after
different gangster song so like this one
is soliloquy chaos first ones moment of
truth I mean it's all kind of influence
like that it was really about that
hip-hop foundation and making sure that
those drums was just like yeah biggest
day it just gives it a real solid feel
and I think people will relate to that
it creates the world's worst but one of
the things I was explaining it's like
the speed of hip-hop it happens at the
speed of thought so if you really ran
into Luke and then all of a sudden boom
there's gonna be a beat that's all it
takes get to kick that whoop that ass
Wow come down and bring the ruckus and
upper boat rubbers to kick buckets and
he kicked somebody across the damn room
you know what I'm sad you can't buy that
right yeah that's dope we have music
that is inspired by tribe called quest
but at the same time inspired by wu and
ennio morricone and we all came together
and said that we want to make something
great not just for black people are
minorities just something great that
just happens to be based on our culture
brothers like me been waiting for since
I was 8 years old and now was he and I'm
ecstatic it was one of those things
where I was like yo never chance to make
history
much happens in the shadows people fear
what they can't see these places our
reputation rmx